[Musique]
salut à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8 de
l'été une édition consacrée au sport
évidemment pendant cette émission je
vais lancer quelques défis à des
sportives illinois ce que nous avons
subies cette saison je reviendrai
également sur des personnages marquants
que j'ai rencontrées cette année je veux
parler de dix gros show le passionné de
football et xavier delpy l'apnéiste
champion d'europe mais tout d'abord je
vous propose de découvrir ou redécouvrir
certaines disciplines méconnues le
tchoukball le kin-ball cela ne vous
parle sûrement pas et bien pourtant les
jeunes manif à sa vie jouer dorénavant
pendant les vacances scolaires ils ont
pratiqué ces disciplines atypique
le tchoukball et le kin ball de nom
étrange pour des sports de balle plutôt
simple expérimenté pendant les vacances
à magny les hameaux pourtant si les
jeunes manica sont séduits
reste que les règles ne sont pas encore
tout à fait assimiler
c'est une balle qu'on lance sur une
sorte de trampoline et qui on a fin
d'exercice et fallait c'est une balle un
flash et il fallait passer la pilule
plus de balles
2 le côté des adversaires
le tchoukball vient de suisse et c'est
une sorte de passe à dix améliorer
mélangeant handball volley et squash
piles et de se faire des passes sans que
l'adversaire puisse les intercepter
c'est ensuite de tirer dans la cible il
faut que la balle rebondisse par terre
avant que l'adversaire ne les rattrape
et voilà donc il n'y a pas de cible qui
est propre à chacune des équipes le kin
ball vient du canada c'est ce sport
spectaculaire où les joueurs peuvent se
saisir du ballon avec toutes les parties
du corps l'idée étant qu'il ne
rebondisse pas au sol coûte que coûte le
kin ball c'est c'est alors non on
appelle ça en fait pour ceux qui jouent
un peu dans la rue avant de jouer aux
deux freins dauphine donc c'était on
envoyait un ballon on appelait un prénom
et on devait le rattraper là c'est un
peu le même principe ça joue pas sur
trois équipes composées de quatre
joueurs et donc il y à un protocole pour
l'appellation de l'équipe qui doit aller
récupérer le ballon et donc ce gros
ballon qui est envoyé en l'air doit être
récupéré par un ou plusieurs membres de
l'équipe qui a été appelé avant qu'ils
ne tombent par terre si cette équipe là
n'arrivent pas à le récupérer c'est les
deux autres équipes qui obtiennent les
pentes les animateurs de manier la
mauvaise derrière la découverte de ces
deux sports faire passer un message aux
enfants
si bien le tchouk que le kin ball sont
des activités sportives ou les enfants
sont jamais mis en contact il n'ya pas
d'insécurité les enfants sont là sont
pas livrés à se faire mal en tout cas et
c est nous sommes énormément basée sur
la notion de respect et de fair play
en france une trentaine de clubs
proposent la pratique du juke et du kin
ball
[Musique]
chaque année la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines accueille le
championnat de france de kayak polo
mélange comme son nom l'indiqué de canoë
kayak et de water polo mais aussi de
handball ce sport spectaculaire est en
pleine croissance et rap essaie de tirer
sa paille et du jeu reportage réalisé
avec julie rocha soir
attention le kayak polo il y un contact
la mise en jeu résume la discipline en
plus d'être un bon kayakistes le
poloïste doit être explosif endurant et
surtout adroit avec le ballon
deux équipes de cinq joueurs
s'affrontent sur un plan d'eau d'une
trentaine de mètres pendant deux
périodes de dix minutes ils peuvent se
passer le ballon à la main ou à la
pagaie mêmes dribbler c'est un peu comme
au monde où tous les joueurs sont à la
fois défenseur est à la fois attaquant
après chacun ses préférences et ses
positions on a des commandes on a des
ailiers en général les ailiers ce sont
les plus rapides et les centraux c'est
plutôt les dégâts les plus costauds ceux
qui tiennent bien leur bateau qui sont
bien que ce soit arrivé en france en
1984 le québec fneeq un vrai sport de
contact à tout moment le porteur de
balle peut être poussé à l'eau par
l'adversaire c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
aspects les plus spectaculaires de la
discipline qui fait des poloïstes et
spécialiste de l'esquimautage express
techniques permettant de remettre le
bateau à l'endroit en quelques secondes
ça peut être violent oui on a des
castrats grille donc ya des coups de
pagaie parfois assez rarement sur le
visage mais bon même un ballon sur le
nez ça fait pas de bien mais c'est vrai
que c'est un jeu très très physique on a
des bateaux adaptés avec des mousses à
l'avant à l'arrière des gilets renforcée
sur les côtés qui permettent de nous
protéger de les côtes cette saison
quatre vingts équipes pratiquer le kayak
polo dans l'hexagone de son côté trappe
se bat pour son maintien en nationale 4
[Musique]
en début de saison nous nous étions
arrêtés sur l'acquis budo cet art
martial issu de l'ère médiévale enseigné
à magny les hameaux l'aïkibudo prône des
techniques de combat où la notion de
partenaires priment sur celles
d'adversaires reportages réalisés avec
elodie moi quand je suis au bout et je
suis là
l'aïkibudo ou la voie des énergies
unifiée cet art martial créé à l'ère
médiévale par les chefs de clans
japonais arrivé il ya seulement 30 ans
en france est enseignée au budo club de
magny les hameaux l'aïkibudo reste un
art martial de défense toujours dans une
volonté d'équilibré où il faut utiliser
les mouvements de son partenaire pour
riposter et le mettre à terre tout en
gardant le contrôle l'est qui vise aussi
bien effectivement un art martial de
défense comme le voulait mettre chiba à
l'origine de l'aïkido on utilise
toujours l'énergie en fait de
l'adversaire pour le canaliser et la
retourner contre lui on considère
vraiment la personne qui travaille avec
nous c'est notre partenaire il ya un
respect qui est très important au niveau
de l'équipe aussi pour ça que j'aime
bien faire le distinguo qu'avec ce n'est
pas un sport de combat c'est vraiment un
art martial l art martial est là pour
vraiment développer l' harmonie avec le
partenaire les mouvements de claix
articulaires sont tout aussi importants
que l'apprentissage de la chute sans un
contact parfait avec le seul les
ripostes peuvent devenir dangereuses
d'où l'importance de contrôler contre et
partenaires à la fois une retenue qui
permet de voir le quotidien autrement la
sortie du tatami une philosophie qui
sont non agression ce cas une un des
fondements la discipline peut-être un
peu plus de calme par rapport aux
agressions de la vie de tous les jours
au stress de tous les jours comme on
vient on vit des situations stressantes
contrôle et finalement ça nous aide dans
la vie de tous les jours peut-être sur
des situations un peu je dirais
inhabituel agressive il va avoir une
réaction un peu comme on va voir sur le
tatami le maniement des armes et l'autre
facette de l'aïkibudo du couteau à la
lance les techniques de combat sont
regroupées sous le terme de kobudo
quelle que soit la technique il n'y a
pas réellement d'affrontements pas de
vainqueur ni de vaincu mais deux
partenaires sur le tatami
[Musique]
je vous propose désormais de nous
arrêter sur le horse ball un sport
spectaculaire où les cavaliers se passe
le ballon comme au handball et c'est à
la base de loisirs que ça se passe c'est
si vers nous avions suivi une rencontre
du championnat régional allez c'est
parti on y va
le horse ball est une sorte de basket
rugby à cheval deux équipes de six
joueurs s'affrontent sur deux périodes
de dix minutes pour marquer un but dans
un panier située à trois mètres
cinquante de hauteur l'équipe en
possession du ballon doit faire trois
passes minimum
leur ce bol est donc un sport
spectaculaire où parfois les contacts
sont pour le moins rugueux et pas
seulement entre cheveau à partir du
moment où on se bat on s'engage pour le
ballon effectivement il peut y avoir des
des des contacts assez virulent mais il
faut savoir que le règlement est fait
pour protéger le cheval et le cavalier
donc même quand on se penche au
ramassage donc pour ramasser les ballons
de foot les parterres normalement on est
obligé si on ramasse pas le ballon de
laisser le ramasseur tranquille pour
qu'ils puissent ramasser ballon parce
que là on est exposé au danger
effectivement avant de jouer horse ball
il faut d'abord être cavaliers et
maîtriser son cheval aux trois allures
pas trot et galop mais ce sport est
aussi exigeant pour les chevaux ils
doivent être dressés pour ne pas avoir
peur du ballon apprendre à effectuer des
courses très rapide et s'arrêter au
civil des attitudes nécessaires pour que
le couple soit performant la complicité
entre le cheval et le cavalier je veux
dire si le cheval et le cavalier ne
s'entendent pas on a un couple qui
fonctionne pas et donc c'est difficile
après un couple qui ne fonctionne pas
c'est difficile de s'intégrer dans une
équipe aussi où tout le monde va se
retrouver pour que le collectif
fonctionne correctement
dans ce derby matches s'impose face à
chambly 9 buts à 5 et assure sa montée
en championnat de france
[Musique]
après avoir découvert ou redécouvert des
disciplines méconnues je vous propose
désormais d'aller à la rencontre des
sportifs et de les voir dans des
situations un petit peu différente du
contexte habituel et pour commencer
honneur aux dames nous sommes à l'heure
actuelle au gymnase pierre de coubertin
montigny le bretonneux évidemment
l'entrée du handball est à mes côtés
gabriel par leur capitaine de l'équipe
fanion et stéphane paysans l'entraîneur
bonjour à tous les deux bonsoir alors la
saison s'est terminée il ya quelques
jours même les entraînements aussi
comment vous avez jugé cette saison vous
finissez cinquième après cette saison
régulière en fait une très belle saison
encore une fois par rapport à l'année
dernière mais dans le même les mêmes le
même place au classement 5e
l'entraînement c'est fini mercredi
dernier depuis le 15 août andy était
donc ça faisait un peu long là
maintenant on est sur le recrutement de
la saison prochaine il nous manque
encore deux filles sur la base arrière
on a une récupère une bonne gardienne de
but et on espère viser la montée l'un
prochaine mais tout dépendra si on à ses
deux arrières ou pas parce que sinon
l'effectif est encore un peu pauvre
quand tu as dis bon et après presque 11
mois passés ensemble vous tapiez pâtit
avec les jeux
avec certaines seraient plus non je
plaisante mais non non non
des compétiteurs on est on est là pour
gagner des matchs donc chacun chacun et
musiciens évidemment la saison s'est
très très bien passé là dessus a dit pas
de problème gabriel situé là ce soir
c'est parce que dans ce module de
l'émission je vais lancer quelques défis
comme je disais tu as me 131 buts cette
saison 5e meilleure marqueuse je vais
proposer de passer au gardien cette fois
ci et moi je vais faire donc des jets de
7 mètres on va faire un petit concours
de jets de 7 mètres 10 tirs chacun son
tour aux tirs chacun son tour au gardien
et la condition c'est que si moi je
marque trois buts sur les dix j'ai gagné
le concours on y va on va peut-être
s'échauffer un petit peu avant alors je
vais faire des passes
oui
[Musique]
tout
mais pour ce défi gabriel par l'horaire
n'est pas venu seul après avoir perdu
d'un petit tir je me confronte à fanny
jean baptiste et à la gardienne de
l'équipe mélodies jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'incline une nouvelle fois d'un but
avant de sauver l'honneur sur un ultime
jet de 7 mètres décisif face à melwood
[Musique]
merci beaucoup en tout cas c'était très
très sympa mais j'ai quand même réussi à
faire deux arrêts si on dernière scène
mais surtout réussi à cadrer 14 tirs sur
quand même ce qui est quand même
vachement bien et puis il monte à plus
apercevoir effectivement que dans les
buts faut beaucoup d'appuis surtout
beaucoup de réflexes et choisir son côté
infos sur wii où ça tellement vite soit
sept mètres la c7 m série de sept mètres
après mais dans l'intérêt flex de tennis
je pense auto cerveau pas mal mais j'ai
senti que j'avais
l'habitude libyen comme les tennismans
disent bien la trajectoire de balle mais
là tu dis bien trajectoire ce que tu es
quand même souvent sur les bonnes
trajectoires donc gestation fut il ya
des cas sur trois quand même à gagner
bien sûr trois fois ci merci en tout cas
stéphane de l'accueil bonne intersaison
bah merci ce que je sais que ça va être
il va dire locaux préparation un
recrutement et puis on en soit le 14
octobre 14 août sur la piste voilà on se
reverra minutes pour pour la préparation
pas de souci merci avec beaucoup de
plaisir
oui
[Musique]
après un premier défi presque remporté
au handball à montigny avec les
féminines et les joueuses de stéphane
paysan je suis désormais à versailles au
gymnase mont boron avec virginie
aurensan pivot de l'entente au chesnay
versailles bonjour bonjour à toi ça lui
anthony ça va oui tout va très bien
ouais ça va alors si on est aujourd'hui
ici c'est pour une raison petit peu
particulière la saison est terminée vous
avez fini première de votre poule de
saison régulière accès aux demi finales
et vous monter en nationale une j'ai un
petit défi à tous proposés on va en
parler juste après mais avant cela je
vais vous voulez savoir un petit peu de
ton impression sur cette fin de saison
c'est phase finale du côté de tours et
ce titre manqué c'est ça a été dur à
digérer ouais vraiment très très dur ben
surtout on s'était préparé un pour ce
week-end un peu particulier puisque ça
n'arrive pas très souvent dans une
carrière et puis ben on est passé
complètement à côté 1 de notre demi
finale donc beaucoup beaucoup de
déception on n'a pas du tout réussi à
notre notre challenge qui nous attendait
et puis ben à côté de ça après voilà on
était chacune de notre côté un peu à
réfléchir à ce match sans pour autant un
voile a essayé de de passer outre cette
défaite puisque c'était vraiment très
très dur à digérer puis seront mobilisés
le lendemain pour faire une petite
finale c'est pas très très motivant et
puis on vous l'avez quand même eu cette
troisième place et on voulait quand même
notre revanche puisque ça ne s'abîme ça
faisait un partout par rapport aux
playoffs et donc on voulait au moins
terminer sur une victoire pour notre
coach aussi puisque c'était son dernier
match et par rapport à cécile et alex
aussi qu'ils arrêtent et donc bon je
pense qu'on a réussi quand même voilà
notre notre troisième place mais après
bon ça laisse un goût amer quand même
par rapport à la saison puisqu'on
voulait à tout prix aller chercher ce
titre au moins du moins aller en finale
qu'est ce qui a manqué sur c'est sur ce
final fort c'est peut-être un manque de
fraîcheur on sait que vous étiez pas
beaucoup sur en terme d'effectif c'est
ça qui a manqué à la fin pas forcément
un manque de fraîcheur ça sera plutôt
voilà l'équipe en face à nous proposer
un jeu complètement atypique avec une
grande qui faisait plus de deux mètres
et des petites qui faisait peut-être un
mètre quarante mètres 50 des petites
jeunes tout au fond rich et nous on n'a
pas réussi du tout adapté donc c'est
vrai que ça a été compliqué à gérer
après voilà on a chacune essayé voilà de
gagner le match individuellement plutôt
que collectivement donc du coup voilà ça
je pense que ça nous a porté préjudice
pour le match je rappelle vous aviez
perdu en demi finale contre les veilles
garnachois mais bon il ya eu cette
troisième place qui compense un petit
peu et puis qui a dû donner l'occasion
de faire une belle fête justement car si
bon on a quand même une médaille de
bronze entre guillemets donc en finit
quand même troisième un équipe française
donc c'est quand même une belle
récompense après oui on a fait un petit
repas d'équipé assez sympathiques comme
tu connais bien les
donc voilà donc pas de souci de ce
côté-là je sais que maintenant la saison
2012 2013 est un petit peu rangée vous
avez déjà commencé à préparer cette
nouvelle saison cette première saison en
nationale une il ya eu des nouvelles
joueuses qui sont arrivés je crois du
côté de l'entente auch n'est versailles
les premiers entraînements se sont bien
passées ben en fait on n'a fait qu'un
homme comme ça à l'entraînement puisque
c'était donc justement deux jours après
le final fort donc voilà on avait déjà
presque tout ranger nos baskets on était
fatigué donc on a fait un seul
entraînement donc avec deux recrues qui
étaient présentes sachant qu'il y en a
une troisième qui pouvait pas être là
puisqu'elle fait partie des moins de 19
ans l'équipe de france donc a été
présélectionné et ensuite donc on attend
encore une intérieure qui pour l'instant
dont on ne connaît pas le nom de ce que
désire voilà donc c'est un atteinte mon
avis le nouvel entraîneur avec son
adjoint donc voilà il ya juste manière
de marquer un peu le coup pour préparer
ensuite la saison prochaine très bien
alors comme tu vois aujourd'hui je suis
en tenue de sport c'est assez rare je
t'ai demandé de venir avec un ballon
puisque je lance des défis et tu en fais
partie ce que je te propose c'est de
faire un concours de lancers francs je
sais que tu as loupé quelques lancers
sur ces derniers matches donc on va voir
si tata régler la mire elle fait 10
lancers francs chacun si jean-marc 4g
gagné 1 4 sur 10 4 sur 10 j'ai gagné ça
fait même pas 50% ça je pense que c'est
à peu près dans mes cordes mais ça peut
être si si je vois que c'est un peu trop
facile on augmentera t'inquiète pas
derrière il y aura une petite surprise
une deuxième phase ii dans ce défi on
est bien sûr un petit bé c'est parti
[Musique]
en réalité ce n'est pas tout à fait
comme cela que ce concours de lancers
francs s'est passé
[Musique]
bon après m'être fait un peu humilié en
tout quatre largement battu sur le
concours de lancers francs on va essayer
du milieu de terrain je te propose cinq
tirs on voit ce qui se passe à la ok ok
allez c'est bon comme en asie
[Musique]
bon écoute comme on aura été égalité sur
un des reporting défi donc je suis déjà
assez content de ne pas avoir perdu les
deux parties c'est déjà pas mal mais
merci un peu cadre de ta disponibilité
et puis bravo pour cette saison ouais
pas au plaisir et puis on espère vous
voir briller si on est parqué nomena
d'année prochaine bon on espère aussi
que ça soit pas fait tout ça pour rien
on était en tout cas ça tient tant à
bientôt
[Musique]
je vous en parlais au tout début
d'émission deux personnages m'ont marqué
cette saison vous avez des petits
chirurgien de la main au quotidien et
dont son temps libre il s'est révélé
être un maître de l'apnée nous l'avons
suivi dans sa préparation au championnat
d'europe avec guillaume france
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le monde du silence
oh
d'huile et tel un poisson le rêve de
beaucoup le quotidien des apnéistes
[Musique]
alors là fait je crois que j'ai
découvert comme un peu tout les gens à
peu près dans ma tranche d'âge par
hugues rondeau avec des magnifiques
l'image du grand bleu partout
moureu xavier delpy a découvert la plaie
il y a deux ans et demi un peu par
hasard lors d'une sortie dans la mer
rouge avec les dauphins depuis ce
chirurgien de 35 ans passe son temps
libre sous
capable de nager sur 200 m sans respirer
vous aviez a connu une progression
fulgurante champion de france il ya
quelques mois le futur élan courtois
fait ces dernières ont dû la scion dans
la fosse de conflans sainte honorine
avancé second championnat d'europe sous
l'eau le nageur de saint-quentin connaît
deux phases la partie plaisir lors de la
cne statique une sensation de la
pesanteur reposante ce moment où les
minutes souvent trop courtes dans la vie
deviennent alors si longue
[Musique]
mais aussi le côté mental ou l'apnéiste
doit se battre contre son corps et hier
7 devient partout qui commence qu'est ce
qu'on appelle la phase de lutte ou là le
corps a envie de respirer et là c'est
complètement l'inversé le mental qui
doit distraire tout doit faire penser à
autre chose qui doit prendre le pas sur
le corps qui a envie de respirer
il est trés dans la tête mais bon il ya
quand même des problèmes de physiologie
parce qu'il ya un problème de
circulation d'oxygène drogue dans le
corps et il ya des gens qui sont
physiologiquement c'est le cas de xavier
physiologiquement différents lots qui
ont une faculté de mieux gérer et
l'oxygène l'homme poisson ne se fixe pas
de limites et compte bien monter sur le
podium des prochains championnats
d'europe à antalya en turquie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette saison nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de 10 brochot aussi attachant
que passionné ce saint quentinois a
dévoilé une grande partie de sa vie au
football au plus précisément à
l'entendre sporting de guyancourt de
1946 à 2013 l'histoire de le lg à
travers son doyen un portrait réalisé
avec elodie moines et patrie jacques de
dixmude
l'aj auxerre à guy roux oui en cours à
gi bronch un même prénom pour une
passion identique du football entre guy
brousseau et le sg l'histoire d'amour
dure depuis 1946
le bailleur
alors âgée de 11 ans le jeune vie en
courtois découvre le ballon rond moi
j'ai jamais appris à jouer au foot on a
appris par nous mêmes on n'avait pas de
chaussures de football un
jouet et des dégâts nos chats boukari
vous n'avez pas connu ça à cette époque
il n'y a pas assez de joueurs pour
constituer une équipe à onze dans une
seule catégorie le stade popieluszko de
guyancourt et le terrain de ses premiers
exploits où il commence au poste de
gardien de but avant de passer défenseur
central et il paraîtrait même qu'il y
possède son arbre personnels lorsqu'ils
se marient à 29 ans give sacrifier sa
passion pour sa vie de famille moi je
veux pas que tu arrêtes non parce que
tout ce quart est après prennent une
brioche qui sauva je trouve que c'est la
f1 tu t'es trop gens vont arrêter de
manger j'avais soir ensemble parce que
le lundi avait réunion le mardi avait
entraînement le mercredi ce n'est des
petits le jeudi les entraînements des
fonds en danger le vendredi soir
ensemble
guy brochot a eu tous les costumes à
guyancourt joueurs entraîneurs bénévoles
ici en bleu aux côtés de l'équipe senior
puis dirigeant en 1972 il participe à la
création du marâtre à une alliance des
équipes jeunes venus de tous
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le sous sol de
la maison faisait alors office de
laverie du club
il avait tout talent un placard avec les
catégories seniors
et le dimanche matin les joueurs
venaient en 3 10 heures et 11 heures
cherchez les maillots le doyen a aussi
vu son sport tant aimé évoluer
j'apprécie le système de jeu mais ce que
j'apprécie pas c'est la coopération des
joueurs ils ont tôt de
distraction autres voiliers nous on
arrivait comme je leur disais les
garrots vous arrivez au vestiaire vous
accrochez vos avis et en même temps vous
accrochez vos soucis et évoqué comment
dire à eelv aux mauvais résultats à
l'école au club tous les enfants
connaissent guy l'entraînement commence
seulement après avoir salué l'ancien
je pense que l'on a vu leurs maisons des
personnes
attaché à des valeurs
[Musique]
une tribune va bientôt voir le jour au
stade maurice baquet le club continue de
grandir il continuera un jour sans guy
brochot mais la relation entre l'homme
et le sg restera à jamais une histoire
d'amour pleine de fidélité et d'humilité
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 dt quant à moi
je vais aller prendre mes raquettes et
taper quelques balles passer un bon été
sûreté mes fils et vive le sport
paris
[Musique]